[Music]
hi I'm Dan Hynes and I'm here with
serene tea hello
I'm very well thank you dinner and we
are playing far cry 4 this is one of the
new sections set in the Himalayas it's
very high up a mountain as you can see
I've seen there's a lot of snow and
currently I'm just sort of scoping out
this base and I just shot a crossbow
yeah I think that was a headshot it
usually comes up and tells you but yeah
so took one of them out with this
awesome multi crossbow that has a lot of
bolts at once and this goat came up and
said I was like no no no you know saw
the crossbow he's down there so did the
goat come up here because you made a
sound but I think that's something yeah
yeah he's usually just sort of wandering
around there's some yaks a bit further
down here as well
so now I'm kind of going over to so not
only do you have to worry about making a
sound that attracts humans we have to
worry about making sounds that attracts
the local wildlife
yes and not just me but these people as
you will probably see up here now this
is it's about patrolling is something
like right I'm gonna take this guy out
you know silently with my crossbow but
then oh my god no there is a snow
leopard and a small start attacking him
and takes him out now you can probably
see he just fired his gun at the Snow
Leopard Oh like and and yes you can see
it's got like some nice fuzz on its fur
which is cool and the crossbow bolt is
in its leg I can pick it up again and
while I'm here I'm just gonna skin him
and you know maybe make the bullet out
of him or something that was pretty cool
very cool
if okay I wanted to save the body itself
would be the whole mangled looking oh no
no because he I'm picking up the guy's
body which is a new feature in Far Cry 4
you couldn't do that in Far Cry 3 before
you could move them if you have them as
like in a melee takedown animation and
you can drag them but once you let go
you couldn't pick him up and put him
down again yeah so that's nice for
stealth I gotta be careful cuz he could
roll down the hill if I put his body in
a kind of like a precarious position but
I think it's fine and what happens if
other NPCs come across his fallen body
do they get sent to alert man yes they
get sent to a work mode you'll probably
hear one of the guys said ah this guy
didn't even hide the body what an idiot
which is
yeah so here we're going up to try and
find the lieutenant to kill him with our
knife and take the photo walking that
wasn't lieutenant but that was a knife
that's not a knife so we still got a
chain take down this dude behind me
which I'm not very good at aiming at but
there we go don't stab yourself with yep
so you still have the syrettes which you
can use to heal yourself and what you
get knocked down as well which is a bit
awkward go across peg-wheel leg so you
still have the healing animations if
you're out of stretch you can like a
bend your iron back into place or dig a
bullet out of it which will probably see
later on I got his picture and yet we
just took a photo with the commander and
it was commissioned that we have to get
out of there so here we are trying the
assault again and we wanted to do
something different by like leaving some
wildlife over to the commander and I
think yep there's the bear he's gonna go
up and do our job for us so how did you
do that you made him fire he's going to
attract the noise that's right yeah you
can throw some bait as well which I
believe I did but now I'm gonna get rid
of the bear and I'm like okay was progra
night at it idea that poor bear did not
stand a chance
Wow look at that bear rag dog back here
again I'm gonna try and use the bear
completely I believe this time so I'm
sort of pre throwing some bait Brown and
it's the cage with the baronet all right
he's out now because I released him I
think he kind of goes for me first so
I'm just sort of bailing and and letting
him kind of get attracted to the enemies
that are around him and he seems to have
done that very nice
and I noticed he threw the bait in the
line were you trying to like believe it
yeah yeah I was I believe that once
people start shooting at him though like
you see here he's gonna go and kill the
person who's actually shooting at him
and I tried to sort of stand back and
sort of watch the fire fight but he's
getting shot from multiple directions so
he doesn't know what to do and I do he
gets taken out yeah yeah so I'm like up
better shoot him down let's go try to
jump over my crossbow bolt apparently
but no he's down I think he looks like
in fact he was trying to climb in scale
though that's right yeah yeah gods
didn't do that before and they have a
lot more verticality abilities this time
so they can actually scale walls off you
which is cool that's pretty cool except
that he was right next to a slope in
which he could've just walked up pretty
much yeah yeah you want to look for
water I'm trying to grenade this guy but
I just can't get the angle right so cuz
they don't bounce in the snow which is
cool so I'm just like alright go for a
takedown nice now I noticed you got
points for that as well oh you have XP
in points oh this is me showing you
kicking system just show how high up we
are just see it go down oh my god
remember now what you're about to fall
death yes so here we are at a fortress
which is like a very large outpost and
we're gonna go and take it over by
killing everyone inside and we're gonna
do that by riding an elephant in
elephants are basically a game which is
kind of good seems very happy to be just
and it's very it obeys your commands
quite quite well which is
often smashing through some walls
everyone's like oh my god there's an
elephant what's going on there's a dude
with the machine SMG like mounted on an
elephant I would start running to I
would this guy doesn't get away because
we're always on the trunk cool so this
time we're trying it again but there's
actually two elephants here so we're
gonna try and bring both elephants into
the base at the same time and see if
that helps us because apparently one
elephant was not another elephant 2
elephants just just randomly on your
side oh yeah so we're gonna hop off him
and just let him he's gonna go on his
own and just sort of start stampeding I
guess is what elephants to be through
the eye you actress are you a target of
that stampede as well like if you get in
the way will you be ah that's a good
question I think if I start shooting it
yes but I'm very careful not to do that
so yeah they'll remember they always
they always remember elephants never
forget so here we yep yep he's like I'm
gonna go in with my friend because
you're on the back of me here we go in
the reinforcements over there so on the
way that's gonna be a chocolate becomes
in double elephant tandem tag-team so
he's gonna go up that way so I'm like
alright I'm gonna let the second
elephant go often isn't as well you set
them free damn I set them free to kill
to do your bidding
yeah what I'm trying to do here is just
kind of get a good vantage point to
watch the elephants wreak havoc but I
believe one of them has died over the
other side of the base so I've only got
this one left there you guys look at him
go there he goes what's that white
marker that's saying there's an enemy in
that direction is this trouble which is
the reinforcements that is now
and I'm like do I have a rocket launcher
nope nope no i don't so i topstitch find
shootable meanwhile the elephant is down
there doing his thing and was their
objective in this one to destroy the
enemy basis and basically you take it
over by killing everyone inside but that
counts the reinforcements if they come
in you awesome to kill them as well I
can hear the elephant just like
trumpeting and going oh yeah he's he's
doing half my job for me which is pretty
cool they're obviously not invincible
though I think they can take a few more
hits than the bear because you know
they've got that thick leathery skin but
I wonder if like you can have interests
be like looks like just go all-in and
leave like a whole whole I want to have
any on screen elephants the game can
handle that's a good question actually
but yeah we should try that once we get
hands-on time bring them all to one
point and be like all right now's the
time elephant stampede so that second
chopper is coming to drop my
reinforcements I don't know but this is
a model which is a new weapon and we can
kind of aim it from the top-down
perspective which is pretty cool times
where the fire the engine just handles
it I don't know but here we go we're
firing it and then I'm getting sniped
out at the same time you can see the
shell landing there kind of blowing the
trees close-range grenade ball traction
here which is you know not advisable to
try at home
so I'm just trying to take everyone down
there's this other tropic umming in as
well because if you take your time there
reinforcements going to come in so you
need to kill them all off before more
yeah yeah pretty much you can disable
the alarm switches in the base
beforehand and the thing about taking
out these fortresses is it's very hard
you'll probably notice I'm getting shot
a lot I'm sort of ducking back to heal
I've just run out of syrettes now so
when I try and heal he's going to do the
healing animation which takes longer and
leaves you more vulnerable so but I like
that like I mean like taking over
fortress as one man should not be an
easy thing exactly this is meant to be a
real challenge and you can kind of see
that it is there we go just digging a
bullet out wrapping it up like a
hardcore man that he is that shot there
just to get the m genus which was really
useful so here we are again trying the
assault with the gyrocopter which is a
new vehicle it's basically a small
one-man helicopter that is extremely
vulnerable because there's no Webber I
can see that so I'm gonna go off and I'm
just gonna sort like range and grenade
cuts down and try not to get shot along
the way this seems like a solid plan
what could possibly go wrong why I don't
know nothing really you know as far as I
can see and looks like they've noticed
you already they have noticed me and I
decide to shoot at me the big threat
when you're up in these is the snipers
and if you end up in a five by three
they have like already laser sight that
shows what they're aiming at you so if
you heart if you hidden that smoke there
you just flew
i I don't know if the stealth extends
that bother hiding at helicopter and
smoke but so completely hidden for at
least obscuring also possibly I didn't
think to try that
yeah so that's type is now my name I
mean I'm trying to aim at him you can't
shoot your foot unfortunately you can
see the cameras whistle pushes the gun
away so that you don't blow yourself up
as human instinct goes I guess I mean it
would be kind of cool to do that but I
started down the gyrocopters beeping and
so on just like oh god Mayday Mayday
Mayday
I checked eject and hissing his smoke
coming out of it which is never good as
far as video games go
and yet you are still at this point I'm
getting higher as high as possible so
I'm just like all right I've never get
ready to bail out okay how will you do
it I believe I have a parachute you have
a wingsuit and a parachute which is a
lot of suits for one man to be wearing
but there we go parachutes up now we
just kind of gently say oh god the
avoiding the chopper blades there they
do actually hurt you if you land which
is nice touch yeah healing myself in
midair which is pretty cool and that was
a lovely landing if I do say so myself
no no no all right how how do you even
like to see their progress there I mean
like I guess you just have to based upon
how many people are still firing at you
yeah basically I'm like it will tell you
once you've killed everyone and you can
keep track of them on the mini-map down
in the lower left-hand corner but it's
it's yeah straight up sort of gun battle
at this point once you've um once your
plan has been ruined as as it just was I
guess it wasn't ruined and we just found
out a new way of not two months ago yeah
exactly
um like I said like it's very difficult
but you'll notice that I'm not sort of
dying straight away I always have that
chance to kind of dump away and heal and
sort of come back from a new position
but there's always a lot of pressure on
you like you've got to be very aware of
you know the open spaces and angles
get a shot on yeah they're ducking into
conference quite frequently this sniper
really keep you yeah yeah it really does
pay to go and observe the fortress
beforehand like we were doing back in
the Himalayas but I didn't get a chance
to do that because I went straight into
the helicopter throwing a lot of
grenades taking that mg post out that mg
post is really good because if you keep
it up I know Chum comes in you can shoot
the chopper down with it so there's a
lot of using the the fortresses sort of
installations against anything that can
kind of come against you you can use the
mortar as well if you're a good shot but
I'm not so down totally totally yeah
hardly cornered but is that something
that they actively do like the enemies
did actively trying to thank you you
know absolutely absolutely
and and they'll call it out as well
they'll be like oh I'm flanking him or
he's over there or he's they're very
good at pointing out what you're doing
and where you are to their to their
comrades English they they are but I
believe they someone speak I want to say
I don't know Oh
so here's me using that in Jena since I
got that brain for some chocolate cheese
and that's it
forretress libera libera he said
interesting it's it's a it's a very
interesting choice of words
so that is far cry for coming out this
November
[Music]